in this video we're going to try to
figure out what four tenths divided by
five is so pause this video and see if
you can think about it before we work
through together or are we really going
to think about approaching this visually
all right now let's work through this
together and let's actually try to think
about what four tenths looks like so if
you view this entire square as a whole
you see that we've divided into ten
equal columns or ten equal sections and
four of those tenths are shaded in so
what you see here in blue is four tenths
but how do we divide that into five and
make sense of it well one way to think
about it is to imagine four tenths not
just as four tenths but to imagine it as
40 hundredths so this would be imagining
it as 40 hundredths so we can rewrite
four tenths divided by five as 40
hundredths divided by five and now we
could think about taking these 40
hundredths each of these little squares
is a hundredth and divide it into five
equal sections and then we could say
well how many hundredths are in each of
those five equal sections so let's do
that so let's see this is 1 this is 2
this is 3 this is 4 and then we have
five equal sections so how many
hundredths are in each of those equal
sections well we can see in each of them
you have 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 so 40
hundredths divided by 5 is going to be 8
hundredths because we have 8 of these
little squares in each of those 5 equal
sections so 8 hundredths we would write
like this and so 40 hundredths divided
by 5 is 8 hundredths then 4 tenths
divided by 5 is also equal to 8
hundredths